the Joe Rogan experience but the copying
thing the intellectual property thing
they don't give espionage is heyou it's
crazy
ya know wha the Huawei thing but [ __ ]
head of Huawei his daughter is being
held captive in Vancouver do you know
about that
yeah but Google that the head of Huawei
Huawei has been accused of some crazy
backdoor [ __ ] they put into routers and
they're really worried about their
technology getting into this country in
the United States has stopped the
production of their cellphones in the
United States like you have to buy them
from somewhere else and bring them in
sort of you know what's it called what's
it called when a it's not connected to
someone who's buy a cell phone it's not
connected to somebody you know under
continent now it's on tether it's like
that though whatever I'll remember it
but you could buy one of those on like
Amazon or one of those tech websites but
you can't get it at Verizon you can't
get it AT&T they blocked all that and
they're like terrified that this company
that has become their number two now
they're right behind Apple like Apple's
number one is Apple no Samsung Samsung
is number one they're number two in
Apple's number three so they've passed
Apple in cell phone production China's
always had I think I had a humility they
were humiliated in their past you know
by the British by a lot of different you
know by the Japanese who are behaved
atrociously but you know that you know
the opium wars were where where the
British were traders were bringing in
opium from India to China and China
developed a major opium problem so the
emperor and the government said this is
a major problem guess what Britain you
can't sell your opium on our docks
you're unloading huge boxes of [ __ ]
opium from India and I know you're
making a lot of money but no because we
have a major addiction problem and
Britain said you're interfering with
free trade and we should be allowed to
and China said you're not allowed to and
so they went to war and Britain won that
war and forced China's to continue
buying opium what there was this called
the opium wars and pull up the load of
and that's why Hong Kong became well
that's why the British took Hong Kong
and leased it for a hundred years look
at this under house arrest in Vancouver
Huawei CFO lives in luxury and spends
her days out shopping where GPS so take
that in life you make her wear a GPS
monitor she it's she has to stick to
11:00 p.m. curfew so by the way she's
tired by 11:00 anyway so her dad owns
Huawei is that what it is yeah she's
well she's the CFO also I don't know
bring her up she kid doesn't her dad on
Huawei it's not what it is it didn't say
that
that's just says she might be a daughter
of billionaire founders so sure okay why
she under house arrest though because
they think Huawei is doing a bunch of
really shifty things well they are the
US wants to extradite her on the grounds
that she tricked banks into potentially
violating Iran sanctions has sparked an
unprecedented diplomatic row yet now
they don't give a [ __ ] they're doing
business on everybody that's showing up
with a briefcase full of cash and
nuclear weapons [ __ ] you and this is
what the United States government is
worried about like these people becoming
the number one technology provider in
the world like if they provided all the
cell phones that everyone in America
uses like what if like they were close
if they came out okay and they got onto
the Verizon network or the AT&T network
with some of these phones these phones
when you look at the the tech people the
tech be like the the people like like
unbox therapy and mkbhd those guys who
develop these of YouTube videos breaking
down the components of cell phones
they're always super favorable about
these Huawei phones they have crazy
cameras some of them have this [ __ ]
insane ability to zoom in really yeah
they use computer learning and they have
that they had are than the iPhone um the
new iPhone is pretty [ __ ] good yeah
but when the wha the latest huawei mate
pro whatever the [ __ ] it was one of them
one of them their most high-end phone
there's a video of them doing a zoom and
that you can't believe how much bigger
they can make something just in the
distance and make it look really clear
image stabilization and crazy I mean
they're about to come out with a hundred
and fifty megapixel sensor on a camera
that's on the phone I mean they're there
and they're going hog-wild with
technology and providing like the state
of the art [ __ ] and just a few years ago
they were like a non heard of brand I
mean five six seven years ago you never
heard about people talking about Huawei
now Huawei has a direct competitor to
the MacBook Pro where I mean a lot of
people think it's the best laptop that
you can buy but it'll display it works
on fingerprints the web camera pops out
of a key like you press a key and it
pops up so people can't see you while
you're jerking off if you're one of
those guys that worries you have from
its watch your hand sure am while these
Huawei computers have figured it out and
they basically but maybe the design of
an Apple MacBook just made it way better
yeah but don't they have of course but
don't they have encrypted don't they
have built-in spyware stuff with some
things with some things I don't think
this is what's funny this is what I like
about my always my argument for the
marketplace because you know you don't
want uncheck capitalism but what's great
about the marketplace is you have to
allow for for creative destruction that
like the the fact that mirror that flip
the camera all the stuff that we had GPS
yet have a GPS you had another little
camera then you had your phone and you
had to allow certain businesses to go
out of business to get all that
technology into one [ __ ] place which
is your phone that we all use and that
requires people to it cry requires
creative destruction it requires like
you know people lose entire businesses
fall down there I'm but a new ones born
imagine if people bailed out all those
portable phone businesses and that's
what we have the government did that's
what what has the market that's what
happened in a government controlled
economy in a socialist economy I promise
you you would have you'd have boards or
or or committees that would decide
whether or not it was fair you you they
would never a government organization
would never allow for that kind of
creative destruction [ __ ] never yes
you have to protect your sex no no but
you would not in its in the situation
like with if China with technology they
they're not like trying to save those
stupid phone
like when those phones became irrelevant
because the cameras on the phones were
bad that's cuz they had to compete when
the cash because that's the compare but
he didn't come out of China I came out
of the West and technology danced
initially innovation and all the all the
innovation everything you see that comes
out of Apple you can swipe all that
stuff don't forget that's all that's all
that came out of the free market that
came out of the gun throat competition
oh yeah no no I'm not but it's
fascinating to me that they just take
that I don't hear it better
[Applause]